one of these 100 bills is real
and the other one is a piece of prop
money made for movies
can you tell which one is which they
both have a blue security ribbon
textured ink and even the smallest
detail
like text from the declaration of
independence
the answer is obvious when you flip them
over bills as detailed as this one
are required to be blank on the other
side that's because if prop makers like
prop movie money in florida
print money that looks too real they
risk
getting in trouble with the us
government
that's what happened 20 years ago on the
set of rush hour 2.
money is more work than it's worth in
the long run
that's greg bilson jr ceo of the los
angeles-based iss
props one of the biggest prop houses in
the world
in 2000 greg got an order for and
printed 1 trillion dollars of prop money
for rush hour 2
most of which was going to be blown up
on screen
and the prop money looks good in this
scene
too good in fact the fake money looked
so
real that some extras on set pocketed
some of it
and tried to spend it at real stores
that alerted the us secret service
which confiscated and destroyed the fake
bills
and the digital files used to print them
it had cost one hundred thousand dollars
to print all of that fake money
so losing all of it was a financial blow
to greg
and iss we didn't try to make fake money
to duke the public we made fake money to
make a movie but we just made the prop
too good
the rush hour 2 incident underscored an
obvious dilemma for printing fake money
the money needs to look realistic on
camera but it can't look
too realistic up close or people might
try to spend it in real life
the problem has become even greater in
recent years
with better cameras capturing more and
more details from the background of
scenes
so the prop industry has come up with
two different types of prop money
each with its own strengths and
weaknesses
for scenes where the cache is filmed
from far away
productions typically use standard grade
bills
the iconic money scene from breaking bad
uses these bills
which were rented from greg and iss
these bills look
real from afar but up close are
obviously fake with lots of clear
differences when compared to the real
thing
the portrait on the bill is poor quality
compared to the real one
and instead of 100 dollars it just reads
100 the smaller details on the bill are
also altered
the seals are a different design and the
signatures on the bill have been changed
then there are the obvious additions
like the prominently displayed
for motion picture use only in fact
if you zoom in to this scene from
breaking bad
while it's blurry you can actually see
that each bill
says for motion picture use only
these changes should keep the secret
service away
but they also mean standard fake bills
are no
good for close-ups so for those shots
movies will
often use high-grade bills high-grade
bills are identical to real money
but are printed on only one side so that
they can't be confused with the real
thing
like the one we showed you earlier which
was printed by rjr props in atlanta
you can see an example of a high-grade
bill in this scene from the 2014 movie
let's be cops an alternate solution that
greg and iss
have been using for the past several
years is to simply use
real bills this is the first version
that they offer
iss will take a pile of completely blank
bill notes and then place
one real bill on the top of the stack
and one on the bottom
making it appear as if the entire stack
is full of real bills
the second method for using real dollars
has a bigger risk attached
but it may be the best option an entire
stack
of real bills iss will get stacks of ten
thousand dollars from the bank
and then deliver them to set while
having this much
cash lying around makes some productions
nervous
it looks great on film and eliminates
any risk with the secret
service that's what they did in this
shot from
ozark i see fake money used all the time
and i think it is appalling because
i'm a property master and i want things
to be authentic
and accurate and look right take a look
at this season one episode of
girlfriends
the fake looking money is distracting to
the audience
while productions may prefer to use real
money
sometimes it's unavoidable like in
scenes where bills are destroyed
or in scenes that require an absurd
quantity
in cases like these greg says that he
will still use
fake money except he certainly doesn't
print the fake money himself
as he still has his cease and desist
from the secret service
so he buys it from prop movie money one
of the few printers that make prop money
the ultimate irony of printing prop
money is that it actually isn't very
profitable standard and high grade bills
sell for roughly 45 dollars for a stack
of 100 bills
greg still has two bills from rush hour
2
that the secret service didn't
confiscate even though these bills
look less realistic than modern prop
bills
he still has them encased in plastic so
that no one can try to use them in real
life
they're a physical reminder of the risks
prop makers take
and the rewards they reap to get that
perfect
money shot
you